Josh earnest the outgoing White House
press secretary kind enough to join us
where are you right now Josh how you
doing din I'm uh I'm in my office and I
think I just dialed in to what is likely
to be my last interview as the White
House press secretary how do you feel
though I mean in all honesty here is is
it emotional it is a little emotional it
is a little emotional it's um this is
you know I've been fortunate enough to
have been with President Obama since his
first day in the White House so it's
almost exactly 8 years since I first
stepped foot in the White will in the in
the west wing of the White House and it
has been a remarkable run it's been the
honor of a lifetime to be here we had
seemed so much so much good news lots of
tragedy too and it's the bonds that you
have with the people that have been on
this ride together is strong and the
ending is abrupt we go from a million
miles an hour and getting the call in to
Dan Patrick radio show to all of a
sudden being a the former White House
press secretary okay but what if
something happens what if something big
happens today and its worldwide
worldwide news and it goes into tomorrow
art are you still on the clock how does
this work yeah I'm on the clock all day
today and God willing that's not going
to happen but I am on the I am on the
clock all day today I've still got my
computer and and everything at my
disposal you know in the event that we
need it and you know at the same time
they're working very aggressively to
ramp up for the next team to come in and
it's actually a pretty remarkable feat
of logistics that you know I will be
here I'm just to check out at five
o'clock tonight but this office will be
totally cleaned and ready for my
successor to sit down here and get to
work it tomorrow so and so you have to
leave it fine work i have to leave at
five does the badge not now you have a
swipe card or a bit like what happens
when you leave at five yeah i get i do
turn in my badge I turned in my secret
service pin I turn in my parking placard
I turned my laptop I turned in my iphone
and and I've I'm relieved of relieved
it's sort of like in the cop movies do
you think the sergeant comes in and says
put put your badge and your gun on your
desk and you know the iphone in my
laptop is my version of my badge and my
gun will they search you before you
leave hahaha I hope not but I I don't
think that they will hopefully then
hopefully they know that I'm also ready
to I'm also ready to give up my badge
and my gun what time does the president
leave so the president will spend the
night here tonight and he will welcome
president elect Trump here to the White
House at 9am tomorrow him and has him
and his wife mrs. Trump and they'll host
a small reception for congressional
leaders and the president and vice
president both the incoming and outgoing
they'll have a you know cup of tea and a
little light breakfast and then they
will ride together the president and the
president life will write together in
the same car to to the United States
Capitol where the inauguration will take
place does the president have a kegger
or something tonight like like does he
trash the place a little bit i mean come
on well we we've had some pretty good
parties here over the left over the last
few days which have been a lot of fun
and there's been lots of opportunities
we've had to honor the service of people
who've been here a long time and to say
a lot of goodbyes and to celebrate what
we've done but my guess is if the
president is anything like me he's going
to be up late packing tonight more
surreal moving into the White House
you're moving out of the way moving in
because moving in I never thought I
would have the chance to work here and I
think that what is true of a lot of
people that i know that i worked with
here is there was a little bit of a
sense that somebody made a mistake and
accidentally had put us on the list to
let us in the building so walking around
here for the very first time was among
the more surreal experiences of of my
life you know leaving is leaving is
different because in some ways it it's
not going to set in that I've left
uh until until I've been gone we're
talking to Josh earnest the White House
press secretary the outgoing White House
press secretary the coolest room in the
White House is what we're cool trim in
the White House is at the Blue Room of
the White House and people can orient
themselves a little bit of you if you've
ever seen the White House before there's
the famous shot of the white house on
the south side where there are balcony
and on the top four of the south side of
the White House is the Truman balcony
which is just off the residence where
the White House or the first family
lives and that is a place that few
people I've never been up there and I
not many people be on the outside the
first family have but it has an
expansive view of the National Mall it's
supposed to be beautiful the room right
below it is the blue room and there is
there's there are these floor-to-ceiling
windows that look foul from the from the
White House and you can see the fountain
out there you have a great view of both
the Jefferson Memorial and the
Washington Monument and it's it's it's
just a beautiful me it's where the White
House Christmas tree goes every year so
it is sort of the center of the
ceremonial rooms in the in the White
House and the last time that my wife and
I were there for a social function which
was just a couple of weeks ago I told i
told her that we need to take a special
minute to look out those windows and
look south and and look at the traffic
on Constitution Avenue look at that
fountain it's a beautiful view and the
thing that I remember is I actually
remember when I first moved to
Washington driving unconstitutional
north to the White House in those
windows and thinking to myself what a
beautiful building and what a special
opportunity it would be to set foot
inside that building a little did I know
I'd have the opportunity to spend just
about every day of an eight-year period
inside that building can you grab mr.
souvenier Josh for the minute I mean is
that I know you've been asked this my
other people but yeah I mean we've been
there for you yeah what what do you have
in mind well what kind of a souvenir are
we looking for here how about a monogram
town
hey I don't want me to disappoint people
but they do have paper towels and
bathroom like on everywhere else how
about a roll of toilet paper I could
probably do that but I don't know that
again there's no identifying school okay
it's not like staying at the trump hotel
it was against is everywhere it's gonna
it's gonna change when McDonald move is
so maybe maybe my successor could get
you some of embossed towels and some
emboss toilet paper but how about a
coaster do you have a White House
coaster um kind of thing tell me what I
can get Josh cuz ah well yes I know
you're you're just going to keep
guessing yeah maybe they're say I've got
a there a couple of things I can you
know what I could send you I can
surprise me you can surprise me let's do
that why don't I surprise you okay and
and you can you can talk about on your
show after you receive it I've got a
couple I've got to get it i got i'll
work in this today all right and if look
if you don't have a job lined up and you
want to come in and be add an ad for a
day I can I can put you to work if you
want to do something like that I would
love that I'm gonna have all kinds of
time as I've been telling everybody I've
been all kinds of time on my end Tuesday
so uh I would love to take you up on
that there'd be a lot of fun hey
congratulations and sure to be pretty
pretty bittersweet walking out there at
five o'clock but great great run and
went through a lot hope you enjoyed it
so thank you Dan I appreciate all your
support over the years and I look
forward to being a having the
opportunity to be more regular listener
now alrighty well thank you josh will
put you on hold Polly wants to talk to
you and we'll see what we can get for me
from the White House yea I'm guessing
all these things I don't know what he
can get me just tell me what I can get
the Dan Patrick show weekday morning on
audience
[Music]